um listen
i'm so sorry but um
[Music]
my show ain't ready adele tells her fans
the show can't go on i'm so sorry it's
been impossible in an emotional video
message shared to instagram on thursday
the grammy winner announced she's
postponing her las vegas residency and
i can't give you what i have right now
um
and i'm gutted i'm gutted and i'm sorry
it's the last minute
we've been awake for over 30 hours now
trying to figure out and
we've been up against so much and it
just ain't ready
i'm really sorry
i'm sorry adele said many factors led to
this last minute announcement including
the ongoing kovid 19 pandemic we've
tried absolutely everything that we can
to put it together in time
and for it to be good enough for you but
we've been absolutely destroyed by
delivery delays and covet half my crew
half my team are down with kobe they
still are
and it's been impossible to finish the
show the 33 year old singer also
acknowledged the many fans who had
already traveled to sin city the first
show was scheduled for friday january
21st i'm so upset and i'm really
embarrassed and i'm
so sorry to everyone that traveled again
i'm really really sorry i'm really sorry
um
we're on it we're gonna reschedule all
of the dates we're on it right now
um
[Music]
and i'm gonna finish my show and i'm
gonna get it to where it's supposed to
be
adele announced in november she was
toplining her first vegas residency so
i'm very very humbled titled weekends
with adele she was set to perform two
shows each weekend through april 16th
the residency comes on the heels of her
fourth studio album 30.
[Music]
adele's music video for her latest
single oh my god dropped last week
[Music]
caesar's palace released a statement
following the announcement saying quote
adele is an incredible artist supremely
dedicated to her music and her fans
creating a show of this magnitude is
incredibly complex we fully support
adele and are confident the show she
unveils at the coliseum at caesar's
palace will be extraordinary
[Music]
you